>> The answer to the question is no.
China will be able to pull itself out of the
financial crisis, indeed
it has already done so, showing very strong
growth.
But nearly all, in fact 95 percent of all
the demand growth in China is
actually going into output in China.
So it is effecting the Chinese economy dramatically
but the spill over
effect on the rest of the world is going to
be relatively modest.
It might add to the rest of the world's output
perhaps a tenth of a
percent of GDP, or two-tenths of percent of
GDP.
Not enough to be a decisive engine in the
end, though.
China has become the second largest economy
in the world or very close
to it, it's not big enough to pull the world
as a whole, that requires
big increases in demand from the developed
world which have economies
in aggregate about ten times as big as that
of China.
So China will save itself but not the world.